while i musical director for the voice
and voice kits so I look after every
kind of aspect of the band and
pre-recorded music and any performance
that goes on on stage so days tend to
vary but if we're on set and we're doing
an actual show record then we've got a
very long day and I have the gallery in
my ear and I'm waiting for cues I mean
actually those are good days for me
because by that point we've done all the
work and we've prepared the arrangements
and we have a good time just performing
music live Dominique I'm production
designer for the voice and voice kids
similar to Dave my work is pretty much
done by the time we get you know camera
ready and the sets done and finished and
polished everyone's using it everyone's
sort of happy with it I can sort of
relax although a lot of time I'm sort of
on ten toes waiting for stuff to go
wrong that's you know my studio day is
really sort of sort of just watching but
you know there's a raft of stuff before
we get there my busiest time is
obviously way before we get into studio
we're an enormous team but then we're a
group of separate teams if you like so
the music team that I'm part of we have
our own communication going on all day
long we have microphones and in-ear
monitors where we can communicate to
each other so it appears that everything
is completely under control but
sometimes where the thing is that we
have to change everything will have to
change key the arrangement will change
and we have a whole team of people that
can suddenly come together to make that
happen and then people don't even know
what's going on but nothing that's
that's it's a good feeling to know that
you can make it happen without causing
too much of a force is insane pretty
much yeah I think looking at the voice
as a whole David's right it is wheels
within wheels you know everyone's
department is full of so many people and
the teamwork to watch is just or
inspiring really because you don't
really know if anything's going wrong
especially you know with our departments
they're so key to the you know what you
see in what you hear on
and I've got such an incredible crew and
they are second to none I think one of
the things that's really cool about the
voices that we get to change songs up
completely so there might be a piece of
musical theater there's somebody wants
to do in the style of radios the machine
or something like that so it could be
that that crazy an idea that we then go
through all kinds of different stages
with and we have to factor in lots of
people's opinions but when it works and
it comes together and you go home and
watch the final result which the sound
Department have also helped with and you
know everybody's hell with you get to
look at it and listen to it and say that
that landed none idea definitely came to
fruition and that's for me the best part
I think my thrill especially for the
first series first show was hearing the
music the first few bars hearing hearing
hearing the set being used and seeing it
come to life so I think you know it
looks great on paper looks great on a
visual but until I stand there lights
are on the the music starts someone
sings it's quite emotional for me my
experience before coming to do the voice
was not really television it was live
concerts so I worked with various pop
artists as musical director bringing
their tours to the stage and it was
through word of mouth actually was
another musician that recommended me and
said this is a very high-pressure music
roll and they said that I might be good
for it so I went through various I tried
to turn the job down actually because I
was I was nervous I didn't think I'd be
able to pull it off so it was a very
difficult early part of my my
involvement in the voice I thought I was
gonna have a breakdown a couple of times
just because of the amount of music that
has to be delivered in such a short
space of time
was quite shocked but then once I found
my feet and got into a kind of groove of
it I've loved every minute of it and
like we were talking about earlier being
part of a team that's another team and
another diliman we all come together to
make it work it's a great feeling
actually mmm yeah same really I mean
it's it's the whole team aspect and that
that drive you on and pushes you and
it's just a wonderful show to be a part
of I think we've got such a brilliant
set of art directors made gin and burn
they gin mainly does all of the creative
gets all of those ready for Jerry the
director and she's always so excited by
and it sort of thrilling to be a part of
that especially on the live shows that's
the buzz there are so many things that
are that are unusual that you pull off
and then you think wow how do we do that
the live shows are very exciting because
you you're listening to so many things
at once to get the timing correct so
from a musical point of view you you're
hearing Emma Willis give cues to you
live but you're also taking a cue for
Pepsi to time a musical moment with a
pyro for example that has to come from
Liz in the gallery do you see what I'm
saying all these things have to come
together and when they do you feel like
you're on top of the world it's a really
nice thing especially on the live shows
like you mentioned already I mean a lot
of our job is making the seemingly
impossible possible you know you get to
a Thursday's rehearsal you might be live
on air on Saturday and you've got this
enormous set to set
you've got to strike it in a minute 40
whilst you're setting another set it's
all those sort of things that people
probably don't think about or realise
goes on probably because they're so good
the crew so good at it it's seamless
Thanks that's a thrilling bit as well
well I'd say be ready for the pace
of its so you know do your work and
prepare and learn as much as you can
from other people who've worked in that
environment but the one thing I would
say is the speed and what people want
delivered at a high standard it
instantly is what shocked me
straightaway and learning how to
assemble a team or work with your team
to achieve that result quickly and
efficiently you know I found that really
difficult the wait times are I was
almost laughing at the things that were
requested you know just thinking well do
tomorrow I'll have this feed tomorrow
you can do that I mean that the same as
me you know the pressure to deliver the
pressure to find a team once you've
found your team you really don't want to
let them go for the same for you you
know you have key people that you try
and hang on to real freelancers so you
you try and sort of get another job off
another job and try and keep them with
you
[Music]
[Music]